Is there anything holistically that can be done or used for a shwanova?
So a shwanova is
a tuber
around a nerve so the nerves in the periphery not in the brain, but in the periphery
have myelin sheath cells and the myelin sheath is made by
shwan cells
in the nerves in the periphery and a shwanova is a tuber
any it could be anywhere, so but it's anywhere on the shwan cells
So what could you do holistically for a shwanova?
Well, what could you do holistically for a tuber?
So again, rife would be my first choice. I would start using rife therapy
to help your body attack that and break that down. So a shwanova is a tuber that's that's typically not gonna be
you know, anything that's gonna be deadly or anything, but it could be very uncomfortable and cause all sorts of issues.
So I would use rife technology
PEMF can be helpful too. Anything that's anti-inflammatory can be helpful so the flavonoids can be helpful with that.
So those are things like curcumin, reds, veritrol, great t-extract,
you know things like that can be very helpful with that.
Shwanova can be formed post-injury
so when you dig to causes of shwanova is usually it's like, you know,
something, you know, on your foot that you damaged or something like that so it can be post-injury, post-stress
typical causes of shwanova. So anti-inflammatories, rife technology, even using electrical frequencies like the 10s unit
can be helpful for that as well.